I remember my aunt brushing my hair when
I was a child I felt this tingling in my
stomach this swelling in my belly all
her attention on me just me my beautiful
Aunt Bea stroking my hair with a fine
bristle brush do you have a memory like
that that you can feel in your body
right now before language we're all
sensation it's children that's how we
learned to differentiate ourselves in
the world through touch everything goes
in the mouth the hands on the skin
sensation it is the way that we first
experience love it's the basis of human
connection we want our children to grow
up to have healthy intimate
relationships so as parents one of the
things that we do is we teach our
children about sex we have books to help
us we have sex that at school for the
basics there's porn to fill in the gaps
and it will fill in the gaps we teach
our children the talk about biology and
mechanics about pregnancy and safe sex
and that's what our kids grow up
thinking that sex is pretty much all
about but we can do better than that we
can teach our sons and daughters about
pleasure and desire about consent and
boundaries about what it feels like to
be present in their body and to know
when they're not and we do that in the
ways that we model touch play make eye
contact all the ways that we engage
their senses we can teach our children
not just about sex but about sensuality
this is the kind of talk that I needed
as a girl I was extremely sensitive but
by the time I was an adolescent I had
numbed out the shame of boys mocking my
changing body and then girls exiling me
for ironically my interest in boys it
was so much
I didn't have any language for what I
was experiencing I didn't know it was
gonna pass so I did the best thing I
could at the time and I checked out and
you can't isolate just the difficult
feeling so I lost access to the joy the
pleasure of the play and I spent decades
like that this low Great Depression
thinking that this is what it meant to
be a grown-up for the past year I've
been interviewing men and women about
the relationship to sex I've heard my
story again and again girls who were
told they were too sensitive too much
boys were taught to man up don't be so
emotional I learned I was not alone in
checking out it was my daughter who
reminded me of how much I used to feel
we were at the beach it was this rare
day my turned off my cell phone put in
the calendar date the beach with the
girls
we laid our towels bound just out of
reach of the surf and fell asleep and
when I woke up I saw my daughter
drizzling sand on her arm like this and
I could feel that light tickle of sand
on her skin and I remembered my aunt
brushing my hair so I curled up next to
her and I drizzled sand on her other arm
and then her legs and then I said hey
you want me to bury you and her eyes got
really big it's like yeah so we dug a
hole and I covered her in sand and
shells and through this little mermaid
tail and then I took her home and
lathered her up in the shower i massaged
her scalp and I dried her off in a towel
and I thought ah how many times had I
done that bathed her and dried her off
but had I ever stopped and paid
attention to the sensations that I was
creating for her I'd been treating her
like she was on some assembly line of
children needing to be fed and put to
bed and I realized I want to I dry my
daughter off a towel tenderly the way a
lover would I'm teaching her to expect
that kind of touch I'm
Jr in that moment about intimacy but how
to love her body and respect her body I
realized there parts of the talk that
can't be conveyed in words in her book
girls and sex writer Peggy Orenstein
finds that young women are focusing on
their partner's pleasure not their own
this is something I'm going to talk
about with my girls when they're older
but for now I look for ways to help them
identify what gives them pleasure and to
practice articulating that rub my back
my daughter says my Tucker in okay how
do you want me to rub your back I don't
know she says it so I pause waiting for
her directions finally she says okay up
and to the right like you're tickling me
I run my fingertips up her spine what
else I asked over to the left a little
harder now we need to teach our children
how to articulate their sensations so
they're familiar with them I look for
ways to play games with my girls at home
to do this I scratch my fingernails on
my daughter's arm and say give me one
word to describe this violent she says I
embrace her hold her tight
protected she tells me I find
opportunities to tell them how I'm
feeling what I'm experiencing so we have
common language like right now this
tingling in my scalp down my spine means
I'm nervous and I'm excited you are
likely experiencing sensations in
response to me the language I'm using
the ideas I'm sharing and our tendency
is to judge these reactions and sort
them and do a hierarchy better or worse
and then seek or avoid them and that's
because we live in this binary culture
and we're taught from a very young age
to sort the world at a good and bad did
you like that book did you have a good
day how about what did you notice about
that story tell me a moment about your
day what did you learn let's teach our
children to stay open and curious about
their experiences like I
traveler in the foreign lands and that
way they can stay with sensation without
checking out even the heightened and
challenging ones the way I did the way
so many of us have this sense education
this is education I want from my
daughter's sense education it's what I
needed as a girl it's what I hope for
all of our children it's awareness of
sensation it's where we began as
children it's what we can learn from our
children and it's what we can in turn
remind our children as they come of age
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]